this one is gonna be bigger than any of
the numbers we've done before so it's
bigger than graham's number it's bigger
than tree three it's bigger than tree of
graves number it's bigger than gram of
trees bigger than tree of tree three it
really is the sort of daddy of big
numbers you say that all the time i know
but it just needs to get bigger every
time um i'm not sure we can really get
much bigger than this we can talk about
that later this number is actually
called rails number it's normally
written like this you'll notice a google
lurking there rio's number really first
came about as a result of something
called the big number duel which was
this sort of contest that took place at
mit in 2007.
[Applause]
so it started with this philosophy
professor a guy called agustin rayo and
another philosophy professor from
princeton adam elgin and they decided to
put on this event this big number duel
as part of this independent activity
period and the basic idea was really
quite simple who could think of the
biggest finite number so this event it
was absolutely packed out you know there
were people trying to appear through the
edge of the door and all sorts
absolutely packed out there were some
very basic rules
so two men one blackboard as a sort of
starting point and the idea was that one
of them would go up to the board write
down a number
and then the other one would have to
come up and write a bigger number you
had to do something novel or different
when you went up to the board okay you
couldn't just add one to the previous
number or add a zero to the end of it
you had to do something new and
different and a little bit novel and you
couldn't use any ideas that had gone
before either so you had to really do
something new you could only write down
finite numbers so you can't be writing
down infinite ordinals or anything like
that it's just finite numbers were
allowed
and the other rule that was important is
you couldn't use any sort of semantic
vocab so what i mean by that is you
couldn't say something like the biggest
number rayo could ever write down plus
one okay you couldn't do something like
that because obviously you know you're
going to get caught into logical loops
it's going to be a nightmare it's
considered ungentlemanly okay so you
couldn't do that the rule was packed
andrea went first now what rayo did was
he wrote down
a series of about 30 or 40
ones so it seems like a large number
obviously it was just the starting point
of course he knows he could write
something bigger than that but he
realized his mistake very quickly elga
came up to the board and just did this
you can see what he's done there he's
turned this series of ones into 11
factorial factorial factorial factorial
factorial factorial factorial factorial
victorious and so on so 11 with loads of
factorial status is clearly a way bigger
number
okay just to get a flavor for how much
bigger this number is 11 factorial is
like 11 times 10 times 9 times 8 and so
on it's about 39 million okay we're
going to do 11 factorial factorial we're
essentially doing 39 million factorial
which is going to be a number like this
if we did another factorial
well now we'd be talking about a number
so we did three factorials now we know
we'd be talking about a number that we
couldn't even write
you know in the sort of as 10 to some
power in any kind of practical way on
this piece of paper at the time we have
available it's just it's just not doable
but here we've got tons of these
factorial so this is a really really big
number so algerian up the ante massively
so he satisfied all the rules did we do
something different so this was this was
a good move so zarya's turn to return to
the board at this point he remembered
something he remembered the busy beavers
and he wrote down busy beaver over
google has he added that to what so this
was his next entry this was his next
entry so the idea was that they were
going to the board somebody would put
one number somebody then comes up with
another number somebody then comes up
with another number and you've got to up
the ante every time and significantly so
but you don't have to have manipulated
no no you don't have to manipulate okay
the idea is just to up the ante on every
round so he comes up with a busy beam so
what are the busy beavers you've
actually done a computer power video
about busy bee the numbers and basically
what the busy beavers tell you they tell
you something about this sort of
productivity of turing machines with a
certain number of states so if i have
the nth busy beaver number this is
telling me something about the
productivity of turing machines when
they have end state so we'll explain a
little bit more about what that means in
a sec this would be the case of where
you have a google state so i'm not a
computer scientist so i'm just going to
explain it with an analogy so i want you
to imagine that you're in a hotel okay
and this hotel has a floor in it and
it's essentially an infinitely long
floor i'm going to start off and all the
lights are going to be off on this floor
but we're going to send a robot around
and this robot is programmed by a
touring machine
and the robot's going to go round and
it's going to switch lights on and off
it's essentially the idea now there's
two states for our robot so state number
one is say that he's in a scared state
so what happens if he's in a scared
state he goes into a room if it's the
dark room if the light is off he will
turn the light on and then he goes to
the room on the left if he's in a scared
state and he goes into a room where the
light is already on
he transfers to the normal state no
longer scared so he's no longer scared
so what happens when he's in a normal
state
okay well again if he's in a normal
state and he finds himself in a dark
room okay he will transfer to the scared
state and if he's in a normal state and
he finds himself in a room where the
lights on he will turn the light off and
move to the right to save power yeah
just just but this is just how the
program's working okay now if this is
all we had
then this is gonna get caught in a loop
okay
so what's important when we're playing
the busy beaver game
is that this process has to stop at some
point okay so in principle what we
should do is we should add some more
states to this and one of them involves
stopping somehow and that doesn't
guarantee that we'll actually stop but
we need to have a scenario where things
stop what the busy beaver numbers say is
is okay right imagine this this robot
has n possible states then this number
tells you what's the maximum number of
lights that are on when he stops
assuming the process stops but the
states could be many and varied they
could involve all sorts yeah all sorts
of things and you're just asking out of
all these possible turing machines with
a given number of states what's the
maximum number of likes you could have
left on at the end of that process and
those are the busy beaver numbers so
these numbers so they start off fairly
gradual but they get big really really
quickly and actually busy beaver over
google so you've got a google state here
is enormous it's absolutely enormous so
the google there refers to things like
scared normal uh
energy-saving all these possible states
the the robot might find itself on we're
saying there's a google different ones
happy sad and each one has a different
action associated with it exactly
depending on whether it finds itself in
the lightroom or a dark room these busy
neighbor numbers are enormous the fact
they're not even computable in some
sense if you give me the number of
states there's no turing machine that
can spit back
the busy beaver number associated with
that it's not even computable this is
how big it is is busy beaver of a google
bigger than tree of a google
i i think the answer is yes
i think the answer is yes
um
yes
maybe yes it's that kind of ballpark you
know yeah oh yeah yeah it's certainly
certainly these these are these are
monsters yeah i think that's i think
this yes okay so how much bigger is this
what's gone before well you certainly
don't need
a turing machine with a google states to
calculate 11 factorial effects you don't
need anything like a google stage okay
this is you just don't need anything
like that so this this this number is
way bigger than anything you find here
then alka comes back to the board and
the game takes on a new phase
essentially and elgar can't just draw a
line through these to make factorials
because he's used that trick yes you've
got to do something new okay you've got
to do something new and novel okay
so what did he do next okay so now they
start thinking about super shorting
machines so the idea of a super touring
machine it knows whether a turing
machine is going to stop or not so what
do i mean by that so you start off with
all the lights off it's got a halting
oracle it knows instantly if this
process is going to end with this
machine and that halting oracle turns
this into a super turing machine it
makes it much more powerful and much
more productive you can actually compute
using one of these super turing machines
you can compute the busy beaver numbers
it's computable with one of these
machines okay so it's much more powerful
that means you can play the same kind of
game again
and you get these super busy beaver
numbers which are going to be way bigger
again okay because you now you've now
got a much more productive machine so
you're capable of generating much larger
numbers many many many more lights left
on okay so then they kept playing this
so then it came up with the super duper
turing machine okay which again then
then it can spot whether the super
turing machine is going to halt and and
generate even larger numbers but we feel
that we're getting away from the spirit
now a little bit because we're doing
kind of the same thing again right so
that's not good writer then came up with
the winning answer
this new number was the smallest number
that was bigger
than this particular number let me
describe this particular number sounds
like you're being semantic we'll come
back to that okay okay
you're right
okay but we'll come back to that okay so
consider any finite number that can be
expressed
using
the language of first order set theory
where the google symbols or less so
we're going to write something in this
language of first order set theory we're
only going to use
no more than a google symbols
what's the largest number we can write
that way
and then think of the one that's just
bigger than that that's rayo's number so
let me explain a few features to that
what's the language of first order set
theory firstly what does that mean well
this is just kind of the language of
mathematics so you have symbols you have
things like upside down a means for all
okay these are quantifiers there exists
which is a backward e and the other
things you can have you can have
parentheses you can have dots which
usually mean such that you have
variables x y z you can have equal signs
you've got these various ingredients
that build up a language and uh it's
first order that means you can only make
references to singular things singular
quantifiers you can't talk about plurals
this is basically the language of set
theory the simplest language of set
theory and
if you want to write down for example
express a small number in this language
it's not very efficient actually so for
example if you wanted to write down zero
you would identify zero with the empty
set the set that literally doesn't have
anything in it and you'd need roughly
about 10 symbols to do that so it's not
very efficient for small numbers again
you may be going up to about 30 or 40
symbols to write down one
and so on okay so it's not very
efficient for the small numbers but for
the big numbers
it gets very efficient you can start
writing down functions and then you can
build the numbers up that way so it's
immediately clear that you're going to
get something that's way bigger than the
tree 3 for example so one thing i could
do is i could define the tree function
using these symbols a modest number of
symbols
okay and then i could then build tree
three quite easily i don't need anything
like a google symbols to do that
right
and i was saying you can use a google
symbols get a number that
gets you all the way up to a google
symbol so you could do tree tree of
itself at google times you get something
bigger than that anyway it's clearly not
the biggest that's just an example of
something that you could do but clearly
you can get things that are a lot really
really really big way bigger than trees
so you asked about doesn't it sound a
little bit semantic clearly did right
the way i expressed it that's because i
didn't express it in the way that rio
expressed it
and it's just the way the easiest way to
think of it rayo was able to express
this in pure mathematical language
okay now he used what's called the
language of second order logic that does
allow you to refer to plurals and things
like that but it had no semantics in it
the way it did it it's quite a dry and
mathematical statement but he's able to
say what i said without the semantics
and that was ryo's number and it won't
and elga couldn't beat him and it's not
for debate whether anybody's ever since
beaten it
there are some numbers that that people
have suggested beat it it's not clear
whether they're consistent it's not
clear whether they satisfy the rule of
doing anything you know you need to do
something new and novel and different so
because obviously you could just
increase the number he puts in there
yeah of course you could but that that's
that's breaking the rules right that's
that's that's not allowed the last thing
i want to say about this is that so when
when i do these um these numbers these
big numbers right well one of the things
we often do is we we tend to sort of
throw physics at it and try to think of
something weird that's that's going on
with it and
blame plug as you know and write a book
about this already
and normally the number wins right
normally the number beats the physics in
some respect and well i'm going to do it
this time again with ryo's number which
of course the biggest of the wall but i
think we need to change let's let's let
the the physics win this time let's see
we can write down rayo's number you know
well the number just shy of it using our
first order set theory okay we're going
to use our google symbols how long would
that take so we're going to write down a
symbol as fast as we can what's the
fastest we can write down a single
symbol
about planck time if you try to go any
faster than that you're going to destroy
the fabric of space-time it's going to
be we really don't know what happens
below but at time scales shorter than
that space-time's just going to go all
quantum we have no idea what's going on
so your hands moving so fast on the
brown paper that you're riding
one symbol per plankton yeah if i did it
any faster than that i break space time
okay as we understand it okay so it's
definitely the fastest i can go so one
planck times about 10 to the minus 44
seconds so if i want to write down all
google symbols to get this number that's
just shy of rayo you don't know what the
symbols are there'll be something no i
don't know yeah no there's something
there's a way there's a way to do it we
won't get it let's assume we know what
it is
okay we're not going to waste time
trying to work out as we know it it's
just there it's been given to us in some
divine way how long is it going to take
us to write down all google symbols well
we're going to take 10 to the 56 seconds
now how long is that well that's about
10 to the 48 cents of the 49 years
if we've got enough time to write that
down
well that kind of depends on the on the
nature of dark energy actually at the
moment what's happening with dark energy
you know the moment the universe is
having this accelerated expansion and
what happens next
sort of will tell us whether we've got
time to write down this number if dark
energy goes away there's a possibility
the universe could crunch and we'll
never get to these times there's a
possibility that dark energy could get
even more accelerated the acceleration
is speeding up and this would be quite
exotic but then the universe would rip
apart before we got to this number but
neither of those possibilities i think
is the most likely i think the most
likely is that dark energy is constant
and we're going to just sort of
the universe is going to die a slow and
relatively painless death so in tents of
the 48 10 to 49 years at that point what
will happen then is we will find
ourselves in the era of black hole
dominance so what that is that's the
time when basically all the matter of
the universe has either just disappeared
to sort of imagine really far distances
or it's collapsed inside supermassive
black holes so the universe is being
patrolled by supermassive black holes
that are swallowing everything and they
dominate so we're still writing down our
symbols we write down the last symbol
we'll rather be doing it in sort of
empty space with nobody anywhere near us
for unimaginably large distances or
we'll be doing it inside a supermassive
black hole
but we can write it down
i mean by a cube
and say
four dimensions
well four dimensions you could take this
picture
and translate it and join the lines but
it gets kind of messy and we can sort of
draw these these trees right we said
that first go the first tree shouldn't
have more than one seed the second tree
should have more than two seeds and so